rachel le bio valley vie dans une
résidence pour personnes âgées
la dame de 93 ans à 10 enfants des
petits-enfants et arrière-petits-enfants
comme tous les résidents elle ne pourra
pas les recevoir à noël j'ai pas le fan
de vélo
on ne saurait voir faudrait pas qu'à lui
et le standard distance on se visite pas
les directives sanitaire pendant le
temps des fêtes prévoit en effet que
seules les visites par un proche aidant
auprès de résidents d'un centre de soins
de longue durée sont permises par le
fait même les résidents n'ont pas droit
à des sorties pour voir leurs proches
les mx hugh johnson les alizés
technologie en personne sur les amis en
souffrent énormément chez les personnes
âgées vivant dans les résidences privées
pour aînés les sorties essentiels comme
faire des courses de m'a permise de plus
une personne âgée qui est seule est
autorisée à visiter une bulle familiale
nicole bozic dubois 67 ans et son
conjoint vie dans leur résidence
le couple qui a deux enfants quatre
petits-enfants est ainsi qu une arrière
petite fille de 5 mois n'iront pas beast
et leur famille à noël pour la première
fois cette année on avait la chance
d'avoir une arrière petite fille alors
on peut pas se voir donc je sortais
beaucoup d'amour des villages afin
d'aider les aînés à composer avec la
solitude pendant les fêtes les
établissements comme la résidence de
rachel distribueront les cartes de noël
et cadeaux envoyés par les citoyens on
va faire des dix noël le 24 et le 25 ils
voient des activités grâce à toutes ces
cadeaux ils seront pas dépourvue de
d'occasions de recevoir des cadeaux puis
d'avoir de l'amour faut de pouvoir
visiter la grand-mère les petits-enfants
de rachel ils m'ont fait une surprise
des bonhommes de neige devant sa
résidence
c'est un cadeau pour moi du contrat ici
nicole germain radio canada saint
lambert de lauzon